if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur stay focused don't get
distracted it's too easy to look at all
the shiny objects around us and jump
onto another opportunity because we
think it's going to be exciting you feel
the momentum but you have to stay
focused on what you're doing tap into
something are you passionately believe
in and stay focused on achieving that
goal until you go out and actually get
it done I got a question from one of my
youtube viewers who challenged me on the
stay focused theme his name was John
great question wrote in saying I don't
know if I should focus or diversify I
look at guys like Richard Branson we've
had a lot of success in diversification
and one of that's the right path for me
so here's the thing John that's a great
point okay I love Milan success it's a
great idea it gives you motivation and
gives you strategies on what to do for
your business is great to look up the
guys like Richard Branson whoever
inspires you whoever you want to be like
learn as much as you can from them if
you love Richard Branson it's great to
look at where he is now owner and part
owner of tons of businesses if you want
to replicate his success look at how he
got started look at what he was doing at
the very early days of building a
business because when he started he was
focused on one business he built up that
business before expanding into other
areas he became great at what he did by
focusing in on the one thing that he was
really good at his first attempts at
diversification actually didn't go so
well in his first company he noticed
that everybody at the company was going
to eat at this restaurant for lunch for
dinner so we decided why not buy the
restaurant so he bought the restaurant
and didn't go well for him whatever he
was trying he was diversifying it didn't
work he learned from it and was able to
build up from there but his first
business he focused like crazy on it he
built it up to the point where he not
only was able to survive off of it
that's your first challenge making
enough money to pay your bills and feed
yourself but to grow a huge Empire from
one business
and then focused on going after other
companies so we're both right you can be
like Richard Branson you can diversify
you can have investments in tons of
different companies but start with one
thing and focus on it and make it
awesome before you open up your
bandwidth because if you do it too soon
you're not going to have success and too
many entrepreneurs try it's so tempting
it's so tempting to jump on something
new because it's exciting and you feel
they can contribute and at the beginning
stages of the company there's so much
passion and energy into it and you'll
find that you just keep doing that you
get to a certain point then you flatline
do you jump to something else you start
over flatline start over flat line and
you never build anything of value so
start off by focusing on one thing make
it amazing make it awesome pour yourself
into it and then focus on doing other
things that you want to do believe for
those are watching please give this
video a thumbs up if you liked it I love
seeing those come in and I want to hear
from you if you have a comment about
this video or question for your own
company leave it in the comment section
below I always read those and I'll make
a video response for you take you guys
I'll see you soon